今日はこちらしていくアップです今日は
テーマはどうして日本人が英語を話せないかと
いうテーマなんですけれどもあの煎じですね先日の u 9分で何か見ながらその
右側にですね色んな彼のビデオ額を推薦されましたね
一つはですねその
まったくこの
カラーだったんですよどうして日本人が英語を話せないかと
あの
バイリンガル近くという女の方ですけれども彼女のあの微量だったんですが
で僕はそれを考えたらねうーん
日本人が英語話ないということがないんじゃないかと
は大事な思いましたよね日本に70年代ですねずっと9年間日本に住んでたんですよ
あのそれで仕事でね色んな会議がありましてね
それで僕はカナダの木材会社の
のは東京団は代表だったんですよ
そして体からいろんな
うちの会社のね
人がきましてねそして
前によっては相手が日本語しか話せなかったんですその時はが僕は通訳しましたけれど
も
管理の場合特に商社とかそういう人たちの場合はでやはり相手が叶えるゆうちょ
前日本人ですよ友情に
の英語
話しましたよねだから
日本人が英語を話せないと言う
技術はないんですよね花 send すべての
その日本語の菖蒲の英語を話せる日本人元を存在しないという意味ですから
そうじゃあ愛ですよねタークさーんこれはイリスがね
a 3
全日本の人口に比べて
まあ巨像かもしれないけれども話せないということはないですよ
だからじゃあどうして
そのたくさんの4の日本人が英語の勉強において苦労しているのかという質問の方が
マーシー各だと思います
まあ何この梅林が9
痴漢
ビデオ見まして
彼女のそのあそれでその通して日本語日本人が英語を話せないかというテーマのリリー
を youtube で多いですよ
だからうそれからはないは離党さのあの
普遍的なはね一つのまあいえば
オプショレーシーですよしていいですよねただ日本人が
祝御的に英語を話せないということはまずないんです
で
by んがぁ地下のそのメインのポイントはですね
アジア人がアジェ人というのもちょっと曖昧ですよねアジア人がイラン人
あのアフガニスた d インド人観光ボディ
まあとにかくアジア人が
日本人よりも枚んだと感情が
まあ言いましたよね結論から言うとまぁ特に
シンガポール人とかインド人が英語より7日本人よりも絵がうまいとただ
処理は当然そうですよああシンガポールとインドがねーこの植民地だったんですよだ
からだいたいと
の英語と
二行ったわけですよかなり norev ねー
でたくさんの英語も今でも聴いてるわけですよ
あるいはインドという国があるその言語がたくさん存在してますから英語が一つの共通
棒にもなってますしあのし学校でもあの中国人やマラエティにインド人が住んでますし
英国の
続6インチでもあったわけですからあの英語が一つの共通部を
あの
でもあるそれが日本のは事情とか違うんですよ
だから日本が同じアジアの中だからと言う
この御方がねおかしいと思います
あの
もう一つの園
by にが地下のそのビデオでねそのリスニング金たくさん聞く聴くことが非常に大切
であったと
そういうビデオ私は非常にまあ
動画ですよだから
基本的にはあの日本人であろうが何度5人であろうが何人であろうそれですね
まずじゃあ
[音楽]
の新しい言葉を勉強するにはたくさん聴いたりたくさん読んだりすることを知らない
わけですね
自分の頭の中にたくさんの単語
たくさんのフレーズを取り入れて取り入れてそれがあのいわゆる
ぱしーはなぁ合意ですねバー carver
選び
まずとして入ってくるんですよねで少しずつ
あの話する機会が多くなってくるとそういうその
パシープラねええ
ボカ3割がだんだんと秋池玲されるはですよ誓うようになってくるんです
しかしまずあのーはですねその新しい言葉に慣れるまでには
上手にはならないただそういう
悲観的な考えた離せない通して我々が離せないという非常にネガティブな考え方はその
ものがよくない
あのああ
絶対できるそういう自信というのが非常に大切だからあの
もちろん日本は三男英語がね
インドのように氏がこのようにあの
たくさん使われてないんですよ
で
しかしそいじゃあ離せないかというといい話したくならばいわゆる
そういう動機があれば絶対できるんだと
それは年齢とも関係ないしへ
まあたちの霊を取ります今まま14歳ですけれども
あのー
こういうどれ午後
弊社の
アラゴ
今勉強している最中なんですよしかしやアラブの国にも住んでないし頭いっていう時に
住んでませんし
トルコですけどアーマーイランにも住んでないから
やりたいならできるできるけれども
no 2このという
馴染みというかなれる機会じっあの機械とやはり刺激
それはたくさん聴いたりたくさん読んだりそして
あー一つその知恵ば入口母と同県できるのはその完璧っていうのは必要はないです
完璧な品種ではないです
楽しく
面白いたら
家会があったら話しますうっ
そのにしかあっても構いません
そしてはバイリンガル地下もいましたがインド人がインド英語
シンガポールディングは強いがボレー5だから日本人が日本の映画が必要だと言いまし
たけどもそれは無理
咲きましたようにインドはあるいは生がポールが植民地であった
そしていろんな言葉や共通
その共存しているわけですから当然英語がその中に一つのしんがぽれー後インド a 4
が出てきたわけですけれども
それは日本の事情とは違います
んど一陣が同一英語
着人がチェックエボ
小いうことあんの非調和のないんです
すいません
もちろん言葉を勉強するときに
バエ
そういうあの
言葉を勉強するときに何かのモデルが
一応ですマネしたいモデル
もちろんインドに住んでるまだ住んでいるいるならばですね周りの人がみんなインド
英語を話してるからそれがモードになりますそれを聞いてそれを招いする
みんなインド英語を話しするチェーンがこれでも同じだけでも日本に住んでいるならば
それ
じゃあ英国なら英国アメリカな
ならあのあれかカナダならからだ
そう言うと手のも手にして
言葉遣い
発音そのたーーー
できるだけ真似するたぁさんからでしょしてあのあるですよ
ええ
わざと真似するんじゃなくてたくさん聞いてたくさん読んで釣るならば自動的にその
我々脳がね
真似するようになってくるんですよ
十分な時間十分な努力十分な動機があれば
だけでもやはり日本人としては日本日本の英語というあの所つの目標というか間にする
のが僕は別に避けた方がいいんですよ
それよりもオシャレな
パティエンタ役に英語
そのああやはりどこかアポロみぇ魅力の rr 岩やてぃんん
僕的にして所してまー言葉付とか5位はそれは
ん
英語で英国はさやか鍋あろうが全然変わらないからそれを自分の頭に入れておく
そして試行しずつこれでてくるんですよ出てきた時に楽しく
もう品牌もしなくてそしてそういうあの
ん
なぜ日本人が離せないかとそういう
何ですか
まああの主観的な
諦めたようなその気持ちじゃなくて積極的に楽しく勉強すれば日本人が英語を話せない
ということはまずないと思います
じゃどうんなら